[Music]
my name is andrew drummond and this is
my story
[Music]
this time i try to make you forget
who you are
and where you came from based on like
you know where my cousins lived when my
uncle phil lived it was kind of like how
it wasn't billy they had a nice house
they had nice cars they lived a good
life they had the money and me coming in
you know into their lives and to their
family it was kind of like how will was
you know coming into a situation where
you're a lot different than everybody
else you carry yourself differently you
come from a different background you
know being born in new york growing up
in a single home was definitely unique
for me because i lived with all women my
mom and sister is all i had growing up
so i didn't have a father figure so my
mom was
playing both roles i tend to
you know get a little worked up having
this conversation but um you know i
always used to ask my mom as a kid like
you know where is he at why he's never
around i always ask the question why it
was definitely difficult for me my mom
she asked me one day would you want to
go on a vacation to connecticut would
you want to get up and move we packed up
our stuff and drove to connecticut you
know going from the fast life of traffic
cars ambulances making sounds all day
long to
silence when i really started to come
into my own is when i moved to
connecticut
never had male figures in my life i was
always my mom and sister similar to
will my uncle phil took me in as well
too
you know he's been a father figure to me
for as long as i can
remember he did everything he possibly
could to make me feel loved he's the
reason why i play basketball he's the
reason why i picked up a basketball is
the reason why i play the way i play the
uncle phil roll is
hit the nail right on the head i think
the story that i had doesn't get any any
closer than that
around the eighth grade going into the
ninth grade is when
like everything just changed for me i
became
andre drummond i want to play in the
nation i'm a player in the state
everything just changed from that from
that year forward yeah this is this is
what i knew i was like yeah i'm
about to be somebody
like i i felt it during this time
because like my confidence was so high
was it was to the point where i was like
you couldn't tell me you couldn't tell
me nothing once i heard my name being
called like i cried because i was like
damn like like this is it like my whole
life is like this is it this is what i
worked for like i made it to where i've
been looking for
and it's finally here
this journey so far has just been
it's been a wild one i think there's so
many
different changes in my life just so
many situations that have you know
approached
and really just
filled me out to the man who i am today
when i think of bel air some of the
stuff that he was going through like i
was dan that's me that deeper
understanding of his mind of like why he
was the way he was and why he actually
ended up in bel air and the story that
we'll had is pretty much similar just to
have that second chance to
you know not go a different direction
and be able to change the way i i did
certain things was definitely a gift
this is great it's pretty cool